and
ask our audience to please be patient
while i
get everything started for the webinar
okay
there we go
uh
oh
okay please hold on for technical
difficulties we're getting this live
streaming started
all right
thank you for your patience
and
welcome to our career master class how
top professionals
thrive through the pandemic
our guest today is lanikola who is the
managing director of kalari capital
we'll hear more about her in a moment
we have a couple of
tips on the controls for webex
please put your
questions into the q a box
that way we can queue them up for bonnie
and
i don't want you to look at
my very large face here i'll fix that
and you can chat
through the chat function but please
again put the questions in the q a box
so that we can keep track of those
we're going to be doing a couple of
polls today one at the beginning one at
the end
and
this first one is about your level of
experience to give
money a
deal for who's in the audience today so
if you are
in the live webex event you'll see the
widget
please answer the poll
and the second question about how you're
doing today to checking in with people
during the pandemic
make sure everybody's
doing okay
and if you are not
live if you're watching on streaming
you can
put your answers in the
comments for your streaming service
about 15 seconds
and this is an interesting distribution
we'll close the poll in about five
seconds
and as you can see
um it's a
trimodal distribution
with a large number of people who are
uh experienced with more than 10 years
some early career people in the three to
five years and a number of people who
are still
at college or university
so it's a good distribution
and
with that i'm going to introduce vani
who is the managing director
of kolari capital
she spent 22 years as a successful
entrepreneur in silicon valley
before building this firm
and now works with entrepreneurs and uh
looks for
young first-time entrepreneurs who she
can mentor and
uh help to scale up to succeed on a
global scale
she's also actively involved in
organizations
that foster both entrepreneurship and
women leadership and we're very pleased
and lucky to have her here today so
welcome bonnie and i'll let you um
go ahead and
introduce yourself more fully
well
as stuart said my name is vani kohler
i'm managing director at kalari capital
kalari is an early stage
um
venture capital firm based out of
bangalore we uh
invest in technology
companies primarily focused on
the india opportunity
i
of course grew up in india did my
engineering
in india but subsequently went to
united states for my master's and then
um
worked there for many years fortunately
having sort of discovered the energy of
startups most of my
career was built around
being with young companies and growing
them
i uh think of myself today even
fundamentally as an engineer
and a product manager so
when we are looking for investment
opportunities we are looking for
interesting product ideas and looking
for product led founders
um
uh in
the i think in the last decade we have
invested in over 100 companies
and generally most of them
are clutter breaking new emerging um
themes you will if you are in india you
will be familiar with many of the names
of the companies that we have invested
in but i'll pause there so we can talk
more
interactively
okay
um so
what
induced you to go from engineering
product management into venture capital
how was that transition
well um
i mean i
the the product management really led me
to be an entrepreneur i started my own
uh companies in the valley
uh
in you know and build them up uh
eventually uh both companies got sold
and
i think
you know
there are many ways to approach
entrepreneurship but sometimes
you have a problem for which you feel
you know how to build a solution and
that's really where the product led
thinking comes into play
um as i did that uh you know seeking
opportunities where you could build
disruptive products
um that same thing led to venture
capital because in a way venture capital
is not that different venture capital is
also about looking for disruptive uh
products and so
trying to do that in a larger scale
versus building one company at a time
and funding other founders versus
who are doing that and doing that well
versus you know me personally being able
to do so it's just
multiplying the impact um
factor
yeah and you and hillary of course has
done that
amazingly well um
so
we encountered the pandemic in the early
part of 2020
and
um it's kind of what
um people call a black swan event it's
something that
you
never plan for
particularly well because you never
even anticipate that it's going to
happen um
so
what was it like for for killari and for
your portfolio companies and for you
personally when
this
event came out of the blue
so um
like with any blo black swan event i
think your ability to make quick
decisions could
help you thrive or at least
survive if not thrive
and
i think the pandemic the question really
was uh
we focus with each portfolio founder
on how do we
create longevity
how do we ensure we protect our
employees well-being which is
financial emotional well-being
and
how do we go about planning for business
continuity
and i think the principles of that are
really apply
uh
at a personal level can apply at a
professional level applies at a company
level the basic principles uh really
don't change that much so we focused on
how much cash do we have
what are critical projects what are
non-critical projects what are projects
that could be transformative for the
company uh in leveraging this
crisis as an opportunity after all you
know
companies have thrived where they see
opportunity in a crisis
and but more importantly on
planning for how long would uh you know
business be
down before it gets back to normal
and i think we did intense
planning restructuring
exercises with all our founders at the
beginning of the pandemic of course it's
a different question
that no one understood how long this
would last so
in order to make any
survival plan
if you're lost in a
desert you have to estimate when do you
think you are likely to be rescued and
if the answer is never then you might as
well give up now
um but you know if you think you're
going to be
rescued in a day or five days or a month
your planning changes right so that's a
different question whether any of us
understood and planned uh for how long
this has lasted
but you know
uh the thought process for at the the at
the start of 2020
was to help each company
you know
think about
their business uh
opportunity but also think about the
sort of
friction
uh in their business today because of
this new variable called pandemic
okay and
did you have
instances of of companies
uh in your portfolio where the business
model was
so radically changed by the pandemic for
example if you had something that was
based on
you know a lot of face-to-face contact
and people had to pivot to non-contact
or remote types of operations where you
were was that a big challenge for your
for your portfolio companies and your
entrepreneurs
i think it
because we invest in a wide
variety of sectors we'd have to take
company by company or at least
industries and
see how they were
affected
and
obviously companies in edtech thrived
because more people were going online
and
willing to pay
for that
um companies that had the significant
retail operations
struggled a lot we have um
a company called um cure fade that
operates a set of gyms um that are
fairly popular called cult
and obviously uh you know that's a high
touch high contact
activity
and
even today hasn't fully recovered
uh you know those companies had to
really do hard digital pivots
as well as like i said uh
plan for their uh
financial
uh
well-being very differently from
sustainability so i think it depends
from industry to industry
uh companies that were already
uh sort of digitally
uh attuned or were doing uh
you know
products that increased um
you know for example our companies in
gaming did very well because people have
downtime and you know that's a different
form of entertainment and uh when all
other things are not there so those kind
of companies did well but um
companies that uh were operating for
example
uh you know we had company that was
operating student housing
and you know they didn't do well so i
think it depends on
different companies and their business
models
yeah i mean student housing
would be a classic example of a company
business model
simply gets wiped out by the the uh
pandemic and
you'd have to pivot to something
radically different to
to
keep that enterprise going
here in california as you mentioned when
you talk about your
portfolio company that operates gyms
the lockdown rules
have changed
up and down
drastically over the last
two years
and
some gym owners have been able to adapt
and
others have
you know
shut down entirely so
it's it's interesting to see how
different companies in different sectors
uh are able to adapt to the pandemic and
as you said
companies in the digital domain
uh some of them are
thriving because of the pandemic because
people have more time to be online um
which brings to another question how has
uh
how have your operations at kalari and
then the operations of your
portfolio companies how have those
internal operations changed in terms of
where people work how people work uh how
you
interact and manage people with and
manage people
due to the you know the pattern of
lockdowns and remote work
um
you know i think many of our investee
sectors
have been able to manage
lockdown and remote work much
better
there are two categories i think to
think about uh when we talk about
you know
being able to work from home
one of course is how easy it is in the
kind of industry you are in
and the more you are in a
product
business and a d2c business direct to
consumer and digital business
as a business model
you can be
obviously more at home
if the gyms reopen and
people have to come in
then
people do come in
uh you have retail operations you are in
aviation you are there are industries
where obviously
um it's not possible
uh to do
very significant digital transformation
but by and large
i think many of the industries that we
are in involved in the business model
largely permit
i think being able to serve your
customers
remotely and i think those companies uh
also
were able to do significant pivots to
how do we keep in touch with our
customers better digitally and so forth
and and then that's the outward facing
part
where your business must be
capable of um
uh
you know remote client management
the second part is remote management of
your employees which i think some
companies do a better job and others not
so well
because
ah
you know when
human contact is lost
uh much of everything becomes
transactional so have you done this
project where is this where is that so
the context
to know people is lost and i know that
you know in the beginning
um it's very
sort of
liberating
to be working from home but after a
certain time
when you have to onboard new people and
those new people need to get to know
their colleagues and the only way they
know them is just from you know very
specific um topical discussions be it as
it may webex or zoom or whatever it is
so how to be creative about building
teams and communities and
you know meaningful
interactions
uh employee
well-being
that i think is a reinvention
for companies to think through and i and
i believe
that we are just at the early part of
the journey overall
all of us in that process
the third of course is
something as much as we
applaud the work from home
on a very long term basis not
everybody's home setup
is convenient or conducive
to be able to do that especially in the
urban context especially in the large
family context
to
sort of have the mind space um to be
able to
really uh do that uh you know uh
segregate uh that kind of um
uh you know space for eight or ten hours
a day um so i think those are some of
the challenges to navigate
uh
for uh companies and i think
you know the book on that
the last chapter on this is not written
meaning
inevitably there is going to be
both employers are figuring out why are
we paying all this real estate
and they
you know uh
in in prime address and they
want uh employees to work from home um
you know save costs right now
for not all employees this is actually a
welcome
uh
you know
option
and so we'll have to find that happy
medium between and and the other way is
true too some employers don't want work
from home and some employees really want
work from home so i think we'll have to
navigate um this happy medium
as well as really kind of continue to
rethink
thoughtfully
on
how do you assess productivity how do
you ensure
you know um that you have as i said
truly supported your employees
well-being uh when you're not
interacting with them
in person so but i think there is a lot
that's happening in the right direction
in this um uh uh you know and uh
uh i think uh many of our portfolio kind
of companies are probably more able to
pioneer it because they are you know
younger nimblers uh
and have a more uh technology adoption
orientation to collaboration
than i think
you know larger
um uh uh
incumbent uh kind of companies which had
a certain work culture which is hard to
readjust or re-adapt
yeah and as you were mentioning the
the adaptation companies make around
real estate and you know do we need the
premier address and
office space
that's a not only a challenge for
companies but it's a challenge for
cities
that have
you know set up their
infrastructure around these uh you know
office developments and and depend on
revenue from them and that type of thing
so
the the choices that
companies make have
wider impacts around
the society around them um
so
how have people
in a certain
psychological way reacted to the
pandemic as
either
a challenge or an opportunity do you see
that
most of your entrepreneurs
look at
this area of change as
this is just opening a different set of
doors
or do you find a number of them who
become discouraged that
oh this is the world is different from
what i expected and i'm not ready to
cope
massive opportunity i mean i think
most of the entrepreneurs see this as
sort of a golden era
massive opportunity everything is
getting digitized
every sector every industry is getting
disrupted
and the you know
technology is
just accelerating in how much it's
embedded in everything and anything we
do whether it's from
inside our homes from home motivation to
you know
our transportation
whether that's
you know public transports or your
private transport business models are
changing from shared models to you know
the form factors are changing
ev
as a core driver so there is you know
just massive changes in every aspect of
our life and you know with the device
proliferation and the screen
proliferation how we
teach ourselves this session for example
won't have really been possible uh
easily pre-pandemic and i think so there
is a certain acceleration that has
happened with the pandemic for digital
adoption by acceleration of a decade if
not more in how people have gotten
comfortable in doing
uh things not just transactions but you
know
how you
build friendships have you even
maintained family relationships right
and i think
during pandemic everybody was doing more
family calls than they did before and
playing cards uh uh you know online
together with families or this or that
or whatever so you know lots of things
from our social interactions have
fundamentally changed so uh and you know
every industry there isn't an industry
you can touch
something as traditional as uh medicine
i mean i've seen uh almost every doctor
adopting telemedicine in some form it's
supplemental maybe oh yeah you came to
see me already but the next one you
don't need to come to see me we can just
video chat or you know whatever it is
right so i think
with um
this kind of a change that has happened
uh if we were to look back to this
moment
let's say
a few years out every five years if we
look back we will see how far
we have changed um
perhaps without fully recognizing it so
i think it's a massive
opportunity um not uh
you know really uh a setback
yeah and
you know it's interesting because
like you said when we look back
we see so many examples of things where
we we might have said to ourselves i
would never do something like that
and then when the pandemic made it
impossible to do anything else we found
out we liked it
so i mean
some people would never have worked from
home or work remotely and then they
found out that you know they they
personally
felt it was a great thing for them
there's an interesting news report
recently about private jet service
in
the united states and how
when the pandemic hit
a lot of
wealthy people decided
rather than interact with people on
commercial airlines they would charter
private jets
but now that lockdowns are
easing up
the private jet service is still growing
because people have decided
you know it's convenient they like it
that type of thing so
these kinds of changes um
can start with the the impetus from from
some big event and then
take root and and change our lives
completely
so
what kinds of
new habits
have
you and your entrepreneurs and your
investees
put in place
that
are different under the pandemic and
seem to be working well
um
i mean i think first and foremost would
be
fiscal habits right
that you know have you
uh
uh look at a
financial management of your company to
be much more
uh you know hands-on
in uh planning that reviewing that
being um
you know on top of that i think that's a
big part of a fundamental change
the second really is you know being
agile
uh and fast paced in decision making
because things are
evolving so
rapidly
being able to
experiment and fail quickly
uh
you know to recognize that and
to continue to reinvent more quickly i
think as a dna
and then
and to quickly adapt as i said
and i also think open to learning there
is just so much change you have to be in
a learning and more
deeper thinking mindset
also to drive decisions i think these
are and these can be institutionalized
by the way this kind of sound
uh you know like qualitative things but
i think you can do things where this can
be institutionalized as a
expectation
and
you know uh also think harder on the
values that work in your favor to
maneuver through uh these difficult
periods um you know what is it that
binds your team together why do they
want to stay together and you know also
a lot of times corporate values can be
just sort of wall hangings
and
um
truly knowing what is the walk the talk
uh you know what are you really going to
do
uh
for people
i think uh you know these are uh some of
the things where
uh this period has taught us the
uh importance of uh pivoting uh facing
crisis with calm and
you know
and also really very clear communication
authentic honest
communication
to employees to
partners
to customers
and
really knowing that you have to pull
together as a team and making that work
i think those are
the you know sort of
habits old or new that have uh
allowed companies to
be effective
um
as you were talking about thinking about
the distance between us in terms of
our distance from the manager to the
employee at the distance from
one company to another
and
it's interesting isn't it that in the
pandemic
while the physical distance is grown in
terms of we can't necessarily be in the
same room at the same time
the
the
practical distance
has
perhaps gotten closer because
here you and i are talking across
12 000 miles of distance and
11 time zones and
you can manage
investees all over the world
your investees can hire talent from
anywhere
people in our business have simply
learned we have
learners who enroll in our programs
online from
60 or 70 different countries
so
do you have a thought about that in
terms of of the the way that the world
is simultaneously
growing more apart because of
the physical limits of the pandemic but
it's growing together because of the
the technologies and habits that we're
developing
um
you know there is the saying
you can be alone but not lonely
or you can be together but very lonely
so i think
the physical distance
or
i think it's a mistake to think that we
are growing closer just because
technology allows us
to be
able to connect okay
it's like
you know we have all the information
thanks to google at our fingertips
but to think that we are learning just
because we have access to information is
wrong
in some ways
sometimes i think of the old-fashioned
when i first left india and went to us
obviously there was no whatsapp
but
also
telephone calls were terribly
international calls were terribly
expensive it was like
believe it or not three or four dollars
a minute
right and as a student that was uh
obviously not that affordable uh it's
sort of like once a month spending five
minutes on a phone call and you know
uh uh
you know spending ten dollars or fifteen
dollars on that
but
um we used to
write letters you know and i would
really
uh anticipate and wait for letters from
home and then vice versa
um and
you know recently in the pandemic as i
was just cleaning out uh
you know
found some of those and there was
something
about it that any amount of here
available all the time online whatsapp
messages don't do because the thought
and the effort
is is not there so
and i use this uh example only to say
just to think that
because technology
can allow us to be
uh together that we really are genuinely
together is a mistake because i think
one of the things that has happened is
we are really not present
right and it's very hard to be present
because you have so many distractions
you're i mean let's just do a simple
poll you know how many of you as you're
doing this seminar have been doing five
other things maybe you know even
listening to music only giving one year
to the conversation here or how many
times have you checked your whatsapp
message or whatever whatever not that
that's wrong i'm just saying i mean this
session is
you know not hard on your
uh uh
sort of uh uh
engagement you can be multitasking and
that's probably fine
but um but i think we do this for very
important things whether it's even when
you're talking to your children or
partner or
you know your boss or your you know uh
peer peers somebody when you need to be
present i think they've almost like
lost the capacity to be present because
it's so easy to be having five screens
and you know doing multiple things and
feeling
productive but you're not so i think
um we have to kind of always continue to
think about
uh and and these are things that
we have to think at a personal level we
have to think at a
uh
you know corporate level uh let's assume
you know you you are a founder pitching
to me and you know because we are not
making really eye contact it's also
because i can so easily turn off my
video and either be present or not right
and you are still talking i think there
is
um and and and it's and it's here and
it's real right we all know this and we
are all guilty of it each one of us have
done this right
so i think how are you present for
things
um
is is an explorer is it is an
exploration it's an important
topic which i think we don't uh
necessarily have full answers maybe
the unfortunate outcome is we are never
really present for anything
yeah i mean
there's an element of that and even you
know well before
pandemic or technology or any of the
things that that
you've mentioned
there is the the notion of learning to
be an active listener
and
pointing out the human tendency of
thinking about what you're going to say
next instead of listening to what the
person is telling you so
there's
um
you know it
that kind of
need to be present and engaged
is very important and
that gets to the issue of management
style
what types of
things have you found
effective
in terms of promoting that connection
and engagement
with you know your employees with your
investees
customers
what would you
what would
am i coming through by the way
are you what
am i audible
yeah you're audible okay yeah so my
question is what types of things have
you personally found
effective in terms of managing
in terms of
establishing that connection
that presence and engagement
when you're interacting with your
employees your investees your customers
well i mean
you know first is a personal resolution
right
if i'm going to give you my time
uh either either i tell you i don't have
the time to give you or if i'm going to
give you my time
then it must be worth it for you worth
it for me so
making a personal resolution that i will
be present so do lesser number of things
but for the things that you do be
present okay i think that's um
that's that's just a personal goal i
think it's important to um
establish especially you know because we
are bombarded by uh distractions and
and i think with
any interaction you have to kind of get
um
creative um in uh truly personalizing
those interactions you know i think
um
it's like this uh
in social media because we are uh
anonymous or at least we are not seeing
the person in face i think we are more
ruder we troll more easily we
are more harsher which would be hard to
do
if you were looking the person in the
eye and doing this
face to face right so
in the same way
i think
it's important to
think about how
you are going to be present and get the
maximum out of your time and you know uh
in each interaction
sometimes if i feel that people are
really not present
then to pause and ask whether they want
to continue now you don't always have
the option of doing that i understand
that it depends on you know what the
conversation is which side of the table
you're on but you know honestly i don't
think there is like a silver bullet
answer to this that says oh yeah i mean
just do this and i found the answer and
you know and it is present i think that
it is it's a significant
problem and all and and i don't think
there is an algorithm
or a platform
that uh you can uh uh
uh you know find although
on a lighter note um there are companies
that we have reviewed that want to
score
your
uh engagement by doing a whole bunch of
algorithmic interpretations based on
your you know um
digital interaction and how focused your
eyes are how many times you are you know
disengaged and
you know all kinds of stuff now whether
that such technology can
uh uh
of course technology can be built it's
very easy to figure out um you know
whether people are truly engaged or not
and give that a score but whether you
know that's a sort of invasion of
privacy uh whether you can install
something
without my knowledge
and then score it and then or if
employers do that
or schools do that uh you know where are
they impinging on individual rights
there are technology is also going to
open up a whole host of ethical
questions
many of which were even contemplated
started contemplated thinking right
um
if education is
digital
then
or online how are you gonna evaluate
the
students uh
you know uh depth of learning uh you
know uh so i think there are so many
questions
that uh we'll only have to discover i
know i don't think i have answers for
everything but i do think
you can personally make certain
choices goals objectives on how you
spend your digital time
and
as you mentioned
the ethical questions that will open up
because of technology one example is no
one would have
expected when facebook started that
a way for you to connect with
you know friends and acquaintances and
chat with them
would turn into the kind of ethical
quagmire that that people
view it as today in terms of privacy and
data and that type of thing
what
um
i think
one
question is what
the the people in the audience can learn
from
um
your
your experience your your investees
experience in dealing with a big
black swan event like this what would
you tell people in order
you know to prepare for the unexpected
i mean
you know
uh
let's think about
when sort of the
uh
terrorist attack happened in mumbai uh
and you know
the taj and
other places right and of course it's a
movie on this hotel mumbai or whatever
what is it that you can do to prepare
for a black swan event like that right i
mean generally there is no preparation
for it
yet some people do better
some organizations do better
and what is that i think that's really
the question there are certain
fundamental things which is
very clear
defined
values
of who you are who you're not right
and
ability to adapt
to completely new situations because
nobody
can predict black swan events that's the
point right
and why it's called that um nobody could
have predicted the pandemic how do you
prepare for it how do you prepare to be
locked down inside a house how do you
prepare
you know for
uh all of us know someone who has
died of kobe how do you prepare for that
how do you
you know there's so many things that you
can't really prepare but what you can do
is develop a
nature to be resilient develop ways in
which you
uh
push yourself to be out of your comfort
zone and all of these are sort of
you know like muzzle memory what they
say
these are just you know again
uh
ability to do it
is additive to
your
uh
ability to manage the unexpected so how
often do you do something that's not
routine or outside of your comfort zone
and if you do that you're probably less
likely to be stressed when something
else unexpected happens so i think the
preparation
for it is not a like a fire drill
okay
i think it's really
uh
um
about
be having a core flexible
approach
to
uh
life and for example
when we talked earlier around business
continuity we're entrepreneurs who
prepared a plan within one week saying
we say look let's prepare a business
continuity plan let's review wait let's
iterate on it and there were once we
would chase chase it took two months and
they just
you know as they say deal with
headlights they're frozen they can't
move you know and they can't
somehow comprehend and accept uh the new
reality so i think in our personal life
in running and as a manager or in
running a business i think the ability
to be
flexible and you know
sort of comfortable to make
rapid
decisions and evolve them change them as
needed but you know
not being frozen
i think that's really important
yeah and
i wish i could source the quote because
i was watching a webinar early in the
pandemic
and it speaks directly to to your point
which
executive from
an investment firm was talking about
they if they had told us we had to all
move to work from home
we would have told them sure that's a
six-month project and it will cost us 10
million dollars to prepare
when it actually happened we did it on
no budget in three days
so
the the notion is as you said
you know you have to be prepared
not for a specific event because you
can't predict that
but you have to be prepared
with the the
habits and attitudes
that allow you to be flexible allow you
to be agile allow you to be
mentally tough during these times of
change and stress
um
do you have any
last thoughts for the folks in the
audience about
where in
this post-pandemic era
they should be
looking at career opportunities or is
that basically
um
or do you have any advice maybe on as we
were just talking
not necessarily specific career areas
but specific ways
to
to look at
managing and
growing their career
you know i always tend to think think
long term where do you want to be
in the next five ten years and then make
strategic decisions each step that gets
you closer on that path
and you know optimize for the long term
not for the short term
so how would i
uh
make that less abstract
let's say you got an offer for a job
that paid you i don't know 20 more let's
say 50 more hundred percent more and you
know
but you went to a place where your
learning is less limited your growth is
less limited
i think that
in the long run if you think of it from
a decade or whatever
it might not actually be
the smartest thing to do so i think it's
important to be in environments of high
opportunity and high learning where you
are challenged you are pushed uh to be
outside of your comfort zone that we
were talking about so i think it's
important um uh to keep learning and
growing
um it's important to kind of have
goals and dreams and uh be persistent in
getting there
and also know that
uh like with anything you are in it's
inevitable that there will be a moment
where you are lost where
it feels not possible and
uh
and
you know you you need
anchors at that time
to recognize
that
that's not the ultimate
answer success is a journey and
you know journeys have sort of sometimes
stopovers okay
um so i think it's important to really
be
uh
a
positive person you know and have
self-belief uh and i think those things
are
too
big qualities that can
uh you know help you
sort of actually do better than you
thought you might do i think we all
have a tendency to underestimate what we
really are capable of doing you know
i honestly think we
if it's more people are
underestimate themselves than we who
were confident about themselves so you
know my my um
suggestion
is uh to live a full life you know to
uh
whatever you do to feel purposeful
about it and work on things that you
really feel passionate about
and and i think if you do those things
uh you will be
a happier healthier person uh that i can
guarantee you maybe even a wealthier
person that i cannot guarantee you
but
but
you know at least you will be a happier
person that i can tell you
very good
um so
if
if i may i'd like to ask some questions
from the audience um
i've collected a few from the q a box
and and there's a couple of
questions on the same theme which is
what segments do you see
as
good potential for startups
um
and some of the questions are asking
about india specifically
globally
what what do you see as as areas that
you you find
have good potential or what would you
tell people to look for
when trying to find an area with good
potential
um
[Music]
you know
we talked about how every area has some
kind of a digital disruption today
of course we can talk about areas we can
say look um
gaming
virtual entertainment
metaphors nfts these kind of things are
all emerging and rapidly growing web 3.0
rapidly growing
um you know
health tech is changing education is
changing
uh
but
i i think it's less important
uh
to think about some big theme i think
it's more important
to think about
what are areas that you have expertise
and you have specific interest in
and
you know you will be able to craft
opportunity in those areas uh regardless
you know
i look at
you know every day so many
entrepreneurs that sort of take
something that is traditional
and somehow they are able to transform
it you know into something else because
they have a new insight on what that
needs uh to be able to
uh disrupt right
so as much as it's important to think
about what are the big emerging areas
it's also important to think about where
is you know disruption happening and how
to
um
translate that into opportunity for
yourself
excellent
um
we have a question from nicholas and
again it reflects a couple of other
questions
um how do you think your leadership
style has evolved during the pandemic
my personal leadership style yeah
um
you know i think
the pandemic has humbled
all of us in more than one way to know
that
no matter who you are
you know you
don't control
uh
predictability of um life uh okay
and uh
so one is uh like i said
to create uh more meaningful
relationships even as a leader i mean
i'm not just talking
uh that as a
person but even as a leader and
you know be um
more how should i say
uh compassionate if you will and i know
it's one of those words that's overused
but um i think
if we didn't come out of this uh
pandemic uh you know
learning how to really
watch out uh for each other
so i think resilience and empathy
uh to uh you know be inclusive of
people and that plays out uh tenfold if
you are truly genuine about it right
so i think organizations should
take that into account and consideration
and
you know build uh
uh work relationships based more on
trust as the center and sometimes
organizations build relationships with
trust deficit right
i think a leadership that's based on
trust at its
core and self-accountability at its core
i think those are uh you know some just
uh thoughts but i also think
you know pandemic uh uh made me a better
learner better reader um
and
just because there was so many things
new to learn and i think it's a habit
not to
drop um
but it also has uh i think
what should i say
a a
lesser
uh
quality uh that
is just so much time on
devices that
um
i think the silent time
to
of thinking time has been
you know unless you plan it and really
value it
uh becomes a problem and i think
leadership is not just about action
and many times we sort of just want
uh to
just do something right otherwise we
feel like we are not being a leader and
sometimes it's about not doing anything
and i think also like i said
really having uh carving
that time
to think and be um silent i think which
is important so you know those are some
broad thoughts
excellent
um
i'm going to ask one last question
because
uh that's all we have time for and i
apologize to everybody for
that but um
i have often seen so
niranya asks
um often seen that venture capitalists
say they are investing in people
um so
once you're satisfied with the
individual or the team that's running a
a
company you're looking at what are the
second and third things
that you look at
um when you're evaluating a company
it's potential investment the second and
third thing are not removed from the
first thing so when we say
people there is of course qualitative
aspects of the people but let's say it's
a business idea
that is in deep tech so you're looking
at
what is really this person's core
engineering progress or pro
or you know kind of really ability to
uh
be that deep
technologist researcher thinker to
create i mean is there a fit so when we
say
you know
uh they're investing in people i think
it's not just about are you a good
person right so um
i think are you a fit for the particular
business that you say you are going to
work on and let's take the other extreme
of something that's a very operationally
intensive
uh you know
problem that you are um
uh trying to um solve uh you know you
want to create done so let's say and
you know uh it's it says so many things
that goes wrong uh just because it's
people intensive uh business and
operations intensive business
and delivering uh
customer satisfaction uh every
interaction is a very complex problem
not a technology wise complex problem
but just a complex problem from a
service industry perspective it takes a
certain personality to be able to do
that so i think there is also a certain
founder fit for the problem that you
look at when you evaluate so you know
the
is there a large market opportunity are
is there a disruptive idea and are you
the right person
for that opportunity
for that business i think that is really
the
evaluation and hence it is subjective
you know it's impossible to
uh know if you are 100 right but you are
making decisions based on
data you have at this moment
in time and what you can see that person
may be a different person five years
from now or five months from now that
business may become a very different
pivot five months from now but here and
now today is where you are evaluating
excellent
that's a fantastic answer i appreciate
that um
and
like i said that's all the time we have
for questions so
what i'd like to do is basically
um say thank you bonnie for being here
and
for
sharing your your expertise your
knowledge your experience
and i will
hold on for a second bring up
our concluding slides
so
here is a linkedin
and i will put that into the chat for
you so that you can follow on
linkedin
do that
and
again thank you for being here
i
really appreciate that
and
we're going to
finish with a poll the audience
one more quick question about
the things you want to learn
yeah to take your career to the next
level
so
give you about 45 seconds to answer that
but
what are the different um
areas
that you think would
round out your personal
toolkit capabilities and when do you
want to get started on
adding those
about 20 seconds to go
and
close the poll in about five seconds
so the
most popular answers are business and
project management and data science
which are
not surprising for this audience product
management is also
popular and so is digital marketing
and it's encouraging that about half of
the respondents said that they would
like to get started right away
right now it's always a good time to
start something
so with that
um
just make a note that we have another
webinar coming up one week from today
which is in the machine learning space
if you are in
ai and machine learning or know of
people who are interested in that this
is a live demonstration
of applying a particular machine
learning model
to a financial problem
and uh
i'll put the link to that in the chat
but in the meantime
again thank you vonnie um thank you all
for being here and we invite you to keep
in touch with us
through our social media networks uh
our handle is at simplylearn
on
facebook twitter and linkedin
funny thank you for for being here again
so
we move into
the chat
just
you